Just a quick one before we dive into today's episode. If you're in private practice, you might know the slightly awkward dance of actually getting paid. The I'll send you a bank transfer later that can often turn into sending chasing emails three weeks on. Well, this episode is brought to you by write-up. And their new tap-to-pay app might just sort that out for you. It turns your existing smartphone into a card reader. Your client finishes their session, taps their card, or. phone on yours, payment lands, receipt sent. No card machine to buy, no clunky terminal,
在进入今天的话题之前，先简单说几句。如果你是私人执业者，你可能了解那种在实际收款时略显尴尬的“舞蹈”。那种“我稍后给你转账”的承诺，往往会演变成三周后还要发邮件催款。好吧，本期节目由Write-up赞助。他们全新的点击支付（tap-to-pay）应用程序或许能为你解决这个问题。它能将你现有的智能手机变成读卡器。客户结束咨询后，只需在你的手机上刷卡或碰一下手机，款项即刻到账，收据也会自动发送。无需购买刷卡机，也没有笨重的终端，
no awkwardness. And because it's built into write-up, the payment links straight to the client's invoice and notes, so your admin actually stays joined up. Write-Up is the practice management platform built in the UK for UK practitioners. Have a look at write-up.com. That's W-R-I-T-E-U-P-P.com. Use code, Marri-A-R-M-A-R-R-E-U-P-P-P-com. Use code, Marri-A-R-R-R-R-R-A. and 30 for 30 days free and 30% off your first six months and see if it makes your week that little bit lighter with much better cash flow. Hi, welcome along to Inner Work. I am Dr. Marianne Trent, a qualified clinical psychologist. Thank you for being here. I had a really wonderful time recording the main podcast episode with Dr. Kate Sherritt. I think it is such a strong episode. And
没有尴尬。而且因为它内置在Write-up中，支付会直接关联到客户的发票和笔记，所以你的行政工作实际上保持了连贯性。Write-up是为英国从业者打造的英国本土执业管理平台。请访问write-up.com，即W-R-I-T-E-U-P-P.com。使用代码Marri-A-R-R-R-R-R-A-30，即可享受30天免费试用，并获得前六个月30%的折扣，看看它是否能让你的工作周更轻松，现金流更顺畅。嗨，欢迎来到《内在工作》（Inner Work）。我是临床心理学家Marianne Trent博士。感谢你的收听。我和Kate Sherritt博士录制的主播节目非常棒。我认为这是一期非常有深度的节目，而且
if you've listened to it or watched it, I would love your thoughts. What really struck me afterwards is just how amazing it can be for us to reflect and to grow and then to kind of think about these relational patterns and think about setting ourselves up for things to go really well in future. And then that obviously impacts on our future friendships, our future work dynamics, our future relationships, if you go on to have new relationships. But then, you know, we might kind of almost look back on our previous experiences, maybe with some difficult feelings, maybe with some grief for what we feel we might have missed out on, or what others might have missed out on, or what could have been different if we had been aware of our own.
如果你听过或看过它，我很想听听你的想法。事后真正触动我的是，反思、成长，然后思考这些关系模式，并为未来做好准备，这对我们来说是多么神奇。这显然会影响我们未来的友谊、未来的工作动态，以及如果你开始新的关系，也会影响你未来的恋情。但是，你知道，我们可能会带着一些复杂的情绪回顾过去的经历，也许会为我们觉得错过的东西，或者别人可能错过的东西，或者如果我们早点意识到自己的关系模式，事情可能会有什么不同而感到悲伤。
own relational patterns earlier on. Maybe you realise that someone you'd previously spent time with was actually a better fit for you than you thought. Maybe you had discounted them as being boring or maybe the decisions you made reflected the person you were at that time and the priorities, the values, the things that were important to you then. But as you age, as you mature, as you change as you develop and as you have new experiences, new encounters, ones that you like and ones you didn't so much, you will change. I do think we should all be malleable, always, we should always be reflecting, to be growing, to be curious and you might just find that if you are making decisions now, you would make different decisions based on your current values.
早点意识到自己的关系模式。也许你会意识到，你以前花时间相处的人实际上比你想象的更适合你。也许你曾因为觉得他们无聊而否定了他们，或者你当时所做的决定反映了当时的你，以及你当时的优先事项、价值观和重要的事情。但随着年龄增长、心智成熟、经历变化、不断发展，以及有了新的体验和邂逅——无论你喜欢还是不太喜欢的——你都会改变。我确实认为我们都应该保持灵活性，始终反思、成长、保持好奇心。你可能会发现，如果现在让你做决定，基于你当前的价值观，你会做出不同的选择。
your current priorities. Hindsight can really feel like 2020 vision, as they say. And whilst we can't go back and change things or fix things all of the time, I mean, no, you might choose to. If you do, come and let me know how you get on. You can also give compassion, send compassion as a bit of a compassionate flow, to your younger self for the choices they made. they did make them with the information they had at the time. I always think it's really interesting when you look back at old photos
你当前的优先事项。俗话说，事后诸葛亮总是看得最清楚。虽然我们不能总是回到过去改变或修复事情，我是说，不，你可能会选择这样做。如果你真的这么做了，告诉我你的进展。你也可以给予慈悲，将慈悲作为一种流动的力量，送给你年轻时的自己，因为他们所做的选择，确实是基于当时所掌握的信息做出的。我总觉得回顾旧照片是一件很有趣的事情，
of people who are no longer with us. And it's like, oh, what would I have like to have said to them? Or could I have warned them in some way? It feels almost voyeuristic looking back on photos of kind of days gone by, people gone by, relationships gone by. And I don't know if you guys have watched the video I did about Lily Allen. Even listening to more recent episodes of her and Makita's podcast, I'm still way behind, by the way. So I think I'm still in 2024, maybe 2025 now.
那些已经离开我们的人的照片。那种感觉就像是，哦，我当时想对他们说什么？或者我能以某种方式提醒他们吗？回顾过去的日子、过去的人、过去的关系的照片，感觉几乎像是在窥视。我不知道你们有没有看过我关于Lily Allen的视频。即使是听她和Makita播客的最新剧集，顺便说一下，我还是落后了很多。所以我认为我还在2024年，也许现在是2025年了。
But yeah, like hearing about some of the things that she's talking about, it's like, oh, now we have that context for how she's described how things went down in her album, West End Girl. some of what she's talking about on the podcast sort of feels like it makes more sense because we have that context, or at least we think we have that context. We don't always have all the information, do we? Yeah, it can feel a little bit like we're doing that with our own life when we look back on even videos in your phone. It can be a really nice trip down memory lane, but can also be really emotional as well. I remember after my dad died, I found it really, really hard to look at photos of him.
但确实，听到她谈论的一些事情，感觉就像是，哦，现在我们有了背景，了解了她在专辑《West End Girl》中描述的事情是如何发生的。她在播客中谈论的一些内容似乎更有意义了，因为我们有了那个背景，或者至少我们认为我们有了。我们并不总是掌握所有信息，对吧？是的，当我们回顾手机里的视频时，感觉就像是在审视自己的人生。这可能是一次非常美好的回忆之旅，但也可能非常感人。我记得我父亲去世后，我发现看他的照片真的非常非常困难。
And my iPhone will kind of automatically store people's faces. If you've got an iPhone, yours will do that too. And then you can click to watch a movie, watch a video of that person. And when I was really hurting, I used to kind of make myself watch that video so that it began to knock those edges, knock those barbs off.
我的iPhone会自动存储人脸。如果你有iPhone，你的手机也会这样做。然后你可以点击观看那个人的电影或视频。当我感到非常痛苦时，我过去常常强迫自己看那个视频，这样它就开始磨平那些棱角，磨掉那些刺。
And so that I began to then see the joy in those photos. again, which had been previously difficult. Looking at someone that you love, who's smiling, who's very much alive, or looking at, you know, photos of you and an ex-partner smiling can feel really complicated. But if we're just seeing the sadness, then we don't necessarily get the joy or the fond reflection. And what we want when we're able to look back on relationships, either people that are still with us or those who are no longer, no longer alive, is we want to be able to look back kind of just with the appropriate grief, a little bit of sadness, but not have it be so jagged
这样我就开始能从那些照片中看到快乐了。这在以前是很困难的。看着你爱的人微笑，看着他们生机勃勃的样子，或者看着你和前任微笑的照片，可能会感觉非常复杂。但如果我们只看到悲伤，那么我们就不一定能感受到快乐或美好的回忆。当我们能够回顾关系时——无论是还在我们身边的人，还是已经不在人世的人——我们希望能够带着适当的悲伤回顾过去，有一点点难过，但不要让它变得那么尖锐，
that we're tripping over it all the time. So if you notice that you really can't look at photos or can't kind of connect to fond memories of times gone by that can be an indication that maybe getting things talked through, worked through, maybe using something like EMDR can help things to lay flat and to level up a bit for you. It's kind of related to what I was talking about, but it felt important. It felt like that might be helpful. If you haven't had therapy or if you think you might be ready for the next chapter of therapy, please do bear me in mind as well. I do offer one-to-one therapy, which happens midweek, Tuesdays, Wednesdays and Thursday mornings, usually. Thank you again for being a member of Inner Work. I love that you're here. Please do let me know
以至于我们总是被它绊倒。所以，如果你发现自己真的无法看照片，或者无法与过去的美好回忆建立联系，那可能是一个信号，说明也许通过交谈、处理，或者使用像EMDR（眼动脱敏再加工）这样的方法，可以帮助事情平复下来，让你感觉好一些。这和我刚才谈论的内容有关，但我觉得这很重要。我觉得这可能会有帮助。如果你还没有接受过心理治疗，或者如果你觉得你可能准备好进入治疗的下一个阶段，也请考虑我。我确实提供一对一的心理治疗，通常在周中，即周二、周三和周四上午。再次感谢你成为《内在工作》的一员。我很高兴你在这里。请务必让我知道
your comments, your feedback, and I will be back along for the next episode next week. Thanks again. Take care. My name's Yana and I'm a trainee, psychological, well-being practitioner. I read the clinical psychologist collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one. And this kind of filled me of confidence that, no, I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself.
你的评论和反馈，我下周会回来录制下一期节目。再次感谢。保重。我叫Yana，是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。我惊讶于通往这一目标的途径竟然如此之多，而且没有完美的路径。这让我充满了信心，觉得我并没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。
So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist, I'd definitely recommend this just to put a, yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
所以，如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你感到安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦开始读，你就停不下来。目前这期节目还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。